for two and a half months Scotland has
improvised corrupt dog used to export
funds to the continent now he sells
door-to-door he sees himself out of
long-term care and is going to people
I'm meeting and it's getting eaten with
there'll also be in Corps say job
satisfaction is far better than what was
doing before staying afloat for society
as a whole as the challenge in lifting
long down
Scotland's First Minister did it with
caution for all our progress this virus
has not gone away it continues to pose a
significant threat to health and if we
move too quickly or without proper care
it could run out of control again very
quickly there have been ball games as
since Andrews but not as we know it now
though on the famous Old Course they've
been weeding the swollen bridge breaking
the bank owes and prepping the
well-known Road Hall for the sport of
touch free golf we're keeping the whole
cops a lot on the other surface just to
protect the soil it's officer that that
doesn't disintegrate we've also put this
film lagging and the bottom there pens
now this is just to stop the golf balls
drop to the bottom of the whole Cup so
when it starts and a golfer can play you
can pull out and you can come and pick
his golf ball Oh without having to touch
the pin therefore been touch free we've
also got these flags and place just the
remaining golfers not to touch the pens
or flags when they're out in the course
Scotland's youngsters won't be coming
back to school until the August term by
then they'll have been out of the
classroom for five months but they and
everyone else will soon be able to meet
members of other households outdoors
that's members plural unlike singular so
for the border he thinks that we're the
only four people in the world he's no
other baby for two months May she our
dog sir is absolutely desperate to see
her friends again so they thought that
they may actually get to just goes to
the park with friends I am it would it
would be it would be great for us yeah
you really want to be
fans but but at the same time you really
wanna not warn about so it's quite hard
to decide isn't it
Scotland's garden centers will reopen as
part of the four phase plan each phase
to be reviewed after three weeks and so
soon these aisles should be full of
customers once more as Scotland
tentatively returns to work and play
they are significant steps however small
James Matthews Sky News Edinburgh